The main shortcoming of DES,
is that it uses a 56 bit key.
Which means the keyspace
is relatively small.
To overcome this,
we can run this multiple times,
each using a different key.
The standard is to run DES three times.
And this is called a triple DES.
The standard is to run the encryption
process, then decryption process,
then the encryption process again.
And correspondingly for decryption, this
will mean to run the decryption process
first, then the encryption process,
then the decryption process again.
And record that with DES, the decryption
process is actually the same as
the encryption process, only that we
apply the keys in the reverse order.
The advantage of using
this order of operations,
is that it supports
multiple key lengths.
In particular If key 1 is the same as
key 3, then the result is a 112-bit DES.
If all three keys are different,
then the result is a 168-bit DES.
If we set key 2 the same as key 1,
then the the triple DES has in effect
become a single DES with key three.
This is useful for compatibility.
For example a triple DES device
can be configured to communicate
with a single DES device, by simply
setting key 2, the same as key 1.